hi I was up really late editing I'm
working on a really fun video for this
week I hope you guys are really gonna
like it cuz it's been pretty fun we
spent the past couple of days working on
it well right now I'm packing to go to
New York I've been working on my packing
skills and trying to only bring a
carry-on but the problem is I end up
with two carry ons one carry-on ends up
being bigger than the other and that's
usually my electronic some people think
it's super simple just to make little
youtube videos well these little YouTube
videos take a lot of things to make them
happen I'm glad that it seems super
simple to all of you guys watching but I
assure you it's not and trust me I do
envy those who have a very simple setup
but I'm pretty particular about some
things I like good audio I like good
quality sometimes I'll have to sacrifice
good audio and good quality for the sake
of just getting the shot I was looking
for a shoe spoiler alert
most girls spend their time and their
money on handbags and I my camera's my
computers my phones that's just what I'm
into I also buy the purses and bags as
well because I have to put the
electronics in something alright well
now I'm gonna pack you guys up so I'll
be switching to either my GoPro or my
g7x we'll see what I feel like guys it
is Wow it's so hot in Santa Monica right
now my mom texted me this morning and
said hey you better transform because
it's gonna be cold in New York I said
okay something's going down
Kyle sleeping get some items I want to
get a sweater I want a pink sweater and
maybe a jacket these are super cute is
also super cute this is exactly what I
was looking for everything is with me
help
11:47 car is coming at 1:30 so I've got
just
I think in this time to get everything
done looking for a very specific bag and
clearly at all this is going to happen
it has to be the perfect side soon you
guys will know what I'm looking to put
inside of this bag these are cute
okay now that's not nothing in that was
going to work
oh my goodness look at the baby puppy
okay good luck on the bag I think I
might just have to use bag that I
already have at home that actually is
perfect but I kind of wanted this same
bag but in a pink
12:32 everything is working out we have
an hour left I still need to make myself
breakfast because somehow that just
slipped through the cracks today please
be free please be free yes oh yeah let's
go let's roll this is how I'm listening
to music in my car because this isn't
working
no see I don't know the term irony wrong
and you guys correct me and it's a bad
habit I apologize but I think this uses
proper isn't it ironic that I was just
talking about people buying purses but I
don't buy purses and yet I went and was
looking for a purse isn't it ironic
Alexa plain ironic violins more set
cancel got a really great pair of yoga
pants though that's not something that I
even needed yeah these are nice time to
repack and then we're gonna head to the
airport first I pick up IDI and drop off
dog food to Jenna I'm not really sure
how I'm getting all these things done
today they're also not done yet so
there's still time for them to not get
done you've got to hold on me err looks
really boring so I'll see you guys in
the car how's it going on this
tell me how many times we're wrong away
I don't want I don't like was it's been
a really crazy day they already know
because they've seen everything else
that sort of happened and I only show
probably one fifth of the craziness so
we made it on the plane but ads over
there over here who both little scenes
so there's no special guys at
it's Maddy
we're here Thank You papa Sh we made it
it's now midnight a little bit after
midnight I edited a lot five hours my
eyes are hurting really bad
hard drive was the only distracting me
on the plane because it's like waking is
bright hard little bit I'm pretty sure
the people next to me like what is she
doing what what is what is this the guy
next to me I thought I was like weird ah
but you're talking to me
yeah texting you the same time oh gosh
okay well now we have like an hour trip
into the city and who knows I hope she's
gonna be the end of this vlog but
there's a really good chance it could be
baggage claim exit we need to go down
this room has a very funny smell to it
smells like new york I can't say I'm a
big fan of New York City English parts
of it that I might like but not Times
Square alright well I guess I'm gonna go
to bed now hope you guys have a lovely
morning or day or night or whatever time
it is that when you're watching us cuz
I'm originally so I think it's like
almost 1:00 1:30 a.m.
oh good morning it feels like a very
quick sleep
I did so Hospital breakfast in a long
time and can you tell everyone how you
like a baby like a big tree extra crispy
to the point where you drop it like
Imperial chatter it did this exactly
what your boots ask more I was like what
if they don't do it they love you do it
can I try one
oh my borrow it's like it's like they
try it try it again divided again divide
it again that's wild yeah I'm good
well I guess at the end of this vlog and
I'm extremely excited for this week
there's gonna be a really fun video
something that I'm very excited about so
I hope that you guys will check it out
and I will see you here tomorrow so
peace bye carry on
did you watch my last video I forget
what yesterday's video was I think it
was on vlog hmm city can't tell we just
got some fake grass job he's completely
destroyed is outside backyard area so we
had to get rid of all the bar hanging
out this vicars
what's his Maddy do you want this ball
go get it Wow are you attacking me
you're so vicious I think somebody
forgot that he's a voice